You know,
I'm on a campus and I'm looking at elementary school kids saying fuck that Nigga
Dick.
And yet you're saying you want to teach them some kind of self respect.
Okay,
sure didn't know this,
but my enemy shooting,
shooting,
shooting my hands.
No,
no shooting.
you don't remember me?
Yeah.
I tried to show some love to my enemies,
but I should have stayed at home.
Like I rather be jealousy.
Got You.
Trying to get ahead of me Niggas kids
when my numbers are low,
you put gating me,
he went out blow.
You gon blow me like in candidate mode.
No.
Now you
got
no
trust.
No Shit.
Yeah.
One time and marker.
That was take one.
That's going to be,
we're all,
we go way back to the marker.
Oh,
I was impressed with his moves.
Yeah.
And one of the problems it was,
I wish I could do that,
but all day,
just taking that away from me.
I'm going to live it.
You can live through me live through me.
Did you write the music?
We're all the way.
Yeah.
Oh good.
It's real good to know.
Okay.
Yeah,
I like the fact a lot.
I liked your movements and your energy and I liked the fact that I could
understand what you were saying.
Whereas so many young singers come up there and you can't hear a word of,
well the message is they're
trying to,
yeah.
So that was good.
Really good.
Do you feel a singer has a social responsibility when he writes it and the
issues he's trying to get across and how he gets them?
Yes and no.
I feel like the,
the singer or the artist has a responsibility to,
to capture what their reality is and the generation I'm in now,
there's this thing of everybody being offended and I think that can silence
voices and do as much harm as people,
I guess spreading what the public would describe it as a negative message,
you know?
So who do you believe to be or want to be your primary audience?
The audience is like,
when I perform are pretty like mixed in general.
Like as far as race and age.
So it's like I just want whoever can relate to it to relate to it,
you know?
But I still want to circle back to the other discussion.
It concerns me with some of the verbage because the young kids,
they're like tape recorders and they do sing all the words.
Can I say words or say what I want to say?
Yeah,
sure.
Okay,
so when you use the word fuck or nigger or bitch,
then you know I'm on a campus and I'm looking at elementary school kids saying
fuck that Nigga v Bush and yet you're saying you want to teach them some kind of
self respect.
Then when you use them and you say this is okay,
that's like endorsing them.
So yeah,
I have a problem with that.
Especially if you're a songwriter,
those kids are going to hear that when it comes to a certain guy,
I would suggest that you take the opposite point.
They're going to hear a lot of negative,
negative things from other places.
They look to you and they respect you and I find that you can be respected with
auction,
that kind of language without that kind of discourse.
Everything you're saying is true.
You know what I mean?
Like,
I feel like there's two truths we should look at.
Okay.
What about life is making these people say these things?
Like what do we need to change about society that's causing this language?
Because the words you're speaking of,
they didn't originate from a song.
You know,
they have,
they have a deep history.
I grew up hearing it.
So when I write a song,
it's just comes out and I feel almost wrong just cutting it out on purpose.
It's that maybe you can just decide when you need to throw the f bomb and just
go for it.
But an occasional f Bob doesn't,
it doesn't ruin it for me.
But if that's every other word out of their mouth,
you know,
like come on.
But if somebody slaps your mom,
then they're a bitch.
You know what I mean?
It's like it's,
it's all context when it comes down to it.
So I definitely,
when I write,
choose the context when I choose to use those words.
Well,
I enjoyed your singing,
but what I would like to know is where I get a shirt,
like that
whole outfit that you have on I would wear.
So I'm glad we shared the same.
Okay.
The reason I chose this one is it has the sunglasses and a smile because I think
you're cool and that's a cooler Moji.
Ah,
the smile is,
I was bopping to the music for my sunglasses around because I didn't want you to
see my look on some of your,
and I was like,
uh,
excuse me.
I use the sunglasses but are like,
you're a total performance.
I picked up that one too,
but there's a part of me that wants to give you this one.
When I found out that you wrote the music yourself,
cause that makes all the difference to me.
You gotta show me Your Emoji.
Pardon me?
You guys are showing me right?
I actually have never heard music like that.
I hit lead.
I guess I lead a pretty sheltered life.
I would have kept all that away from my little children.
I guess it really would be this one.
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
It's like an excellent performer thing.
I'll say that much.
What I said before,
a wink and a smile that expresses it well that we can can the smile.
I really,
this is not my type of music,
not the music I grew up with.
Oh,
no.
Big Door.
Enjoy.
I did enjoy the fact that I could understand what you were saying and your
energy.
I was jealous off.
Thank you so much.
Think about what I said.
Thank you.
Good performance.
Thank you so much.
Different.
Yeah.
Right.
Almost every generation has to,
I'm going to find something that their parents could have jumped.
Yeah.
I think,
I think always getting normal that for some time because they want it done.
What do you do?
It's no worries.
Yes.
Hey guys,
thanks so much for watching this episode.
If you liked what you saw,
please subscribe and leave a comment below.